it holds all the necessities yeah
so we play the middle east now i don't
know who he is you know i i mean i had
met him once before i did oh tell him
about how i acted during this is so
embarrassing remember that one show
where ahmed had done no no okay first
time we ever
i don't even remember but you were the
biggest dick okay just tell them when i
said crazy
so
first of all he comes to this show we
had this great show out in uh newport
beach we were playing we were paying
comics in the city a thousand dollars to
come do a show he comes and he's a
nightmare from the beginning to the end
like this is the biggest diva i've ever
[ __ ] met what did i do you were just
doing all kinds of [ __ ] you were like
you know it was like
get my car and
um yeah yeah
he was just like complaining the whole
time about the show these people hate me
these people i don't want to be here
this is ridiculous how dare you he was
like how dare i met a man
booked me in this shitty he was going on
and on about the show
just the biggest worst diva ever you
know i had to call a man like a man you
need to come down here because i'm about
to kill bobby lee he did not like me no
i just it was the worst but i didn't
know who he was you know
i was like i didn't get it yeah i
thought he was the guy from digital
online you actually thought that yeah
this ugly guy you know he's he's still
bitter is he wearing the glasses and
then you know the glasses of the nose
that they have i thought he was wearing
one of those things
you know that's a little thing that they
do at that thing so what were you guys
conversations you guys even talked no he
was like come on man don't act like that
i'm like [ __ ] you man i wasn't [ __ ] i
was [ __ ] crazy yeah he was crazy i
was [ __ ] crazy were you sober
yeah i'm sober yeah whoa god you just
have diva tendencies he still has diva
oh god don't even get me started
what
you you don't you know what i hate about
you to this day yeah it's like you don't
communicate properly
no he like i have to text you a thousand
[ __ ] times for you to get back to me
you never answer your phone your [ __ ]
voicemail is always full you know how
how does your do you have another phone
do you know how people get in contact
how did they call you yes your the
manager and agent have to call you hey
can you tell bobby that's ridiculous al
and bilber are having him are having him
on a podcast on wednesday they didn't
contact him they can't have contacted me
anything that any he ha anytime he has
to be anywhere it's through me
because he will not reply let me ask you
a question
have you ever heard of ronan
look at me right now right now i'm
asking you a question have you ever you
are not ronin
okay
have you heard of ronaldo you do ronan's
dry cleaning at best okay you know what
a ronin is right a masterless samurai
all right
so what i am is i'm wandering through
these dirt listen
in japan i have a sword and i'm
scratching my back and i'm walking
through these dirt like pathways and i'm
just a wandering samurai just longing
for a home
okay and that's what i know look it's
the best when my friend
there is i've told this story about one
time when we when bobby and i went out
of that restaurant and he was talking
about how he
he was being he was being gross he was
being gross about being bobby lee did i
tell you this story
no it came out of support what's the
[ __ ] about the story this we were coming
out
steve he kept telling steve and i he's
he kept winking and he goes i know that
wing yeah he's like he's like it's so
great to be the korean elvis and he kept
saying it over and over and over again
and he was like i'm the korean elvis huh
babe and he keeps winking at me and i i
felt like i started to feel like rage
inside me because he kept doing it
and so so steve and i didn't tell him or
he he didn't see very well in the dark
and there was there in the parking lot
they had this like chain thing that
blocked the entrance to the parking lot
he trips over the parking lot the the
the chains and he skids on his stomach
they basically superman's on concrete
like a stone in the river when you flick
it right right and all these people come
to his rescue like oh my god you know
and steve and i were in hysterics we
were laughing so hard we were on the
ground just in just in a full-on
connection like we were laughing so hard
and he was so angry at us so because he
was mid-sentence before he tripped he
was like i i am the korean l and then
like
flips over the chain but the crazy thing
is a bunch of people around you it helps
you yeah funny
funny story
hilarious how many butt licks is that
one a thousand whoa yeah you you're
[ __ ] tonight at some point it's gonna
feel like pleasure so i'm just gonna
train my brain to be like this is this
is pleasure this is pleasure i want to
get my teeth involved oh
hi
so chris wataski yes chris wataski
i met him um you know i'm on i'm
reoccurring on a show called love on
netflix recurring recurring recurring on
no recurring somebody corrected me
recurring yeah it's not reoccurring it's
not reoccurring it's recurring
stop stop start over no no
no not start over
i am going to continue to say
reoccurring
because that's the way i memorized it
that's memorized
and no one's ever gonna stop me okay
it's it's the same way he always says
expresso versus espresso and the
barista's always kind of and they give
me an eye and i'm not gonna change it i
know what it actually it is
okay and also when i'm at starbucks i
don't say venti or any of that i say
large extra large
no i'm not doing your language right
italian yeah you no it's not that it
says they want to be cool and they want
to have their own little
[ __ ] you yeah
but i bet when they ask for your name
you say bobby lee from mad tv
he
chris no i don't do that
i don't [ __ ] do that
i don't do that can i just say what he
did at the restaurant the other day a
leader comes in with with a pad and a
pen
to get our order
he thinks the guy wants his autograph
and he's trying to take the order so he
takes the pad from the guy the korean
guy he's like yeah no problem he goes
hey love you love bobby lee gives it
back to the guy the waiter the greater
so confused like oh okay and he walked
away and they came back
[ __ ] pad paper was so embarrassing
yeah i was like sweetie he just wanted
to get her order why did you assume that
so quickly
because he put the paper down in a pen
on the table oh that's weird right and
then he was like hey he said he was a
fan no he didn't the other guy
he didn't even speak english he just oh
[ __ ]
um i'm going to say a mule of the story
of that's gonna it's just gonna bother
you guys but um it's probably gonna
bother you it's gonna bother everyone
but it just it just gave me a mark
so
margaret did a show in san diego once
she invited me right it was sold out it
was like 5 000 seats or something and i
was in awe of it but i didn't watch the
show i stood i hung around in the lobby
so i can get recognized
wait so people would like see you yeah
did people do it yeah because i this is
my like my second or third year i'm mad
oh and that's when like people started
recognizing me you know it's the same
thing when i used to go to the mall yeah
and you should do your laps around
we used to hang out at a food court to
get recognized
and i did it at her show but i remember
like me leaning against like i had this
like funny like
like a bear beanie on
you're like the ones i wear now right
like this one yeah yeah and i was like
wearing these ripped up jeans and like i
was wearing sandals you're trying to be
like a celebrity oh 100 peacock i never
even went in the show
people were like popcorn or whatever
right and i was just kind of leaning
with that oh great so gross that's so
gross that's gross i know i used to do
so many gross things like that dude you
got to test your star power see where
you fit in no i mean do all people do
that or just bobby no dude i heard that
barry sobel told me who's he barry sobo
was a comic from the late 80s he was on
every tv show imaginable but his best
friend was chris rock
and when chris rock and barry sobel did
uptown comedy express or you know
something like it was a
show on hbo of stand up they went to the
beverly
hills mall to get recognized so everyone
does it i think everyone if i think that
if you're a stand-up and when you're on
a tv show there is a little bit of a
transition where
it's different now because now you have
the internet and anyone can become
famous
but i think when there was no internet
and you're because you don't know if
people know who you are because there's
no internet mm-hmm right you you you
can't ch check youtube or hit you get or
there's no way of knowing except if you
go to a mall
so that was your kind of likes you know
i mean your social media likes yeah yeah
right so you would go hang out at a food
court and people what's up or like
crowds of people go around you and
you take photos like you know but
regular photos with regular that was
your your measure of success then and it
actually got you off the couch if you
wanted to know how famous where you had
to get off the couch instead of just
looking at your instagram go to the food
court well also it's it's also live
shows is the way you do it too it's like
um i did this before what i
my first second sketch shows i did
seconds not even famous second sketch
show yeah packed house yeah throughout
the whole show
crazy laughter from me every time i go
on stage crazy laughter so i was like oh
my god i wouldn't be famous i'm someone
like a producer snl's gonna be here oh
my god so what i did was i ran because i
wanted people to see me and like
high-five me so they know oh it's sam
it's the gilbert guy they gotta do the
naked thing so i literally ran out of
the theater outside took the fire exit
just to go all the way to the front so i
can take the escalator back up as people
are exiting out
and i was on my phone
and then i would look up be like you're
like hey are you the guy on the shelf
like hey they'd be like
oh my i do a lot of high fives oh my
gosh
i knew they were going to say this
people like you're going to be on snl
one day oh
that was nope nope did it happen nope it
didn't happen it didn't happen
but i got that oh my you know what i've
done a lot of that to myself at least
you're we're on tv i did it when it was
a [ __ ]
show no i did it i did it
um when i used to open open molly and
mencia you do this maybe on stage i
would hang out the lobby and have people
go whoa you're really good and people go
you're funnier than them or whatever it
feels good though it feels good
i saw them laughing yeah i wanted to say
yeah man
what i thought it was really nice in the
start no i know i did there was a little
i needed my dick sucked before yeah they
didn't they were nice but they were they
weren't sucking my deck they're just
trying to do their jobs i need i need
people to be sucking my dick put in the
writer because that saturday i did a
casino in um sacramento
and as soon as i show up people just
start sucking my dick
not literally but like can we get you
something what do you need are you okay
and i don't need that but papa loves it
papa loves feeling wrong papa loves like
and then i can play like
do weird [ __ ]
like i like it when like before the show
people come up to me and they go can i
get a photo i go afterwards you know if
i have time
like i like acting like i'm [ __ ]
special yeah which i'm not
it might i i know i'm a piece of [ __ ]
but there were like moments where like
hey can you just leave the room a little
quiet to be my you know like just i pull
like little power moves dim the lights
please yeah yeah i love doing that [ __ ]
you know
yuck
you don't like that and then there was a
restaurant only a restaurant in town
they were closed and i go can you make a
call see they'll keep open for us
damn and they go we'll see they called
me kept open and we were there like
hours late yuck and they were at the
whole shut the [ __ ] up the whole staff
stay and i and i purposely ate as long
as i could and this is a i have a
problem with that have you ever oh gosh
this is what i have a problem with
because
that was a special day for them wasn't
it
[ __ ] you
superior
if we go to a restaurant and the line is
extremely long and they don't make
special concessions for him they don't
make you know they don't make um
okay you're gonna make me angry because
i that you're absolutely wrong what
you're saying right if no one recognizes
you at a restaurant and they treat you
like everybody else you always say we
gotta go let's leave
you're gonna be upset
that's because people around there were
like taking pictures and they recognized
you that made you happy no but that one
time with my brother we stood we stood
there for two hours and we waited
that's my point my point is a year ago
we did that my point is i will wait
you know and you're wrong what you're
saying
you're definitely not wrong yeah yeah
i've i've lived with you long enough to
know you yeah you know what you do when
people recognize you you put your hoodie
up and you try to do i don't do that i
have never done that try to hide and
then when they come and you act like
like you have no idea what they're
talking
do you do the paparazzi yeah she does
that she does that yeah
yeah yeah yeah podcasts
when you lie
you lied and i just lied i just lied
right just to make you feel what i was
feeling but i i'm not lying i am not
lying either i'm not lying either like
when fans come up you like you put your
hoodie down and you act indifferent does
that sound like me probably
gilbert does it sound like her though
maybe yeah
maybe that's my point is that when you
lie i lie
and if you're truthful lady i'm truthful
no because this is what you said to me
on um on the way to my sister's birthday
it was you me and my friend shane d in
the car yeah and you guys got into a
very heated discussion about um being
treated um differently by restaurant
owners and you specifically said they
should be happy that i'm there for the
sake of their business i never said that
and then she was like no they shouldn't
yeah you're just like every other patron
and you attacked her like you guys were
over that one time you got pulled over
by the cop and you cried you go i mean
i'm on a podcast like you shouldn't be
giving me a [ __ ] dick
i'm just saying
that sounds definitely like
i was like
when you lie i lie
i fight lie with lie my friend
and don't [ __ ] around all right yeah
none of that's true and whatever i'm
saying is not true but if you keep
flying i'm going to lie we did have a
meeting at a coffee place there were no
seats and claudia yelled i'm on [ __ ]
tiger belly there we go and you know
what that's what you're lying because
that's exactly what delilah does that's
what teletech does that's what it does
yeah imagine if i was that way you are
that way what do you mean imagine
just record yourself [ __ ]
you [ __ ] skanky lying [ __ ] i
oh god god i would never act like that
yeah you do but anyway let's move on and
i know that
i have never also been pulled over in my
life yeah you have let's move on
but see what i mean
bobby
we're gonna roll back to a few episodes
ago where he admits to being a
pathological liar that's fine you don't
have to roll back people could just
listen to it
but also everyone listening right now
knows that they slept king right
i live in a deceptive smog
or a cloud
right and you don't know what's in it
and that's what people love the mystery
of it i could be lying not lying yummy
left right hook you know i'm not there
i'm there right now just listen what i'm
saying right i'm relevant not relevant i
mean all kinds of things are happening
right and that's what the [ __ ] fa and
you kids listening know you know so
whatever this lady is saying kalila is a
lie and i'm the chill
let's go back so date number five
you're like something reminded me when
you were like oh um you're talking about
was it charles fleischer yeah
how he would just like break into
character yeah bobby would do something
very similar but intentionally he would
try to seem more eccentric than he
actually was like he would be driving
we'd be in the middle of a conversation
and then he would just like
like just like do these like silent like
monologues and like but like mouthing
them yeah i purposely do and he would do
like little texts yeah
because he wanted to seem like an
artiste like he was some kind of like
savant
savant
now did you already at the time because
i feel like you see it out you saw it at
that time too um i looked at him like
okay i guess i can live with that i mean
it'll tell you why
no because i thought he maybe had some
type of um
no i'll tell you why why did you do that
because when i was i when i was 22
i worked at a coffee shop called the
panicking
and i liked a band called drive like
jehu
all right they're a math rock band
i love them what's math rock math rock
is just punk rock but it's like
repetitive right and just kind of me i
don't know yeah yeah so anyway um rick
farr was the lead singer and
he was he came in he had one shoe
missing
always no he just walked in the coffee
shop he had a shoe missing oh that's so
cool yeah yeah and you know he had money
he was from del mar yeah right so this
guy has money but yes he purposely knows
you
right uh-huh and then he would he was by
himself and he had one of those hobo
gloves yeah it's summer he doesn't need
to wear his fingers yeah yeah yeah yeah
and you look at his fingers and they
were dirty uh-huh and then he had a
cappuccino like that he had a hell of
like this god i hate this guy
so much
all right you held it like this i'm with
her
buddy this guy i can't even no i mean
that guy you're doing no [ __ ] he's
the best okay he's very talented
so he's holding it like this super
turned right again and then
and then right he
would do twitches oh my god just listen
and drink and then kind of talk to
himself right and i would i would be i
was you know you're fascinated by him oh
yeah i'm doing the coffee but i'm
looking at him you know i mean because
i've all have all his albums and um i
memorized you wanted to be as understudy
yeah and in fact here's another thing
that they do right
drive jehu right you know when they're
on stage see my legs they would he would
play the guitar but he would cross his
legs like this
so you know i would go home and pretend
i'm in a band and would cross
[Laughter]
but i love that because it's like your
fandom is what drove you to do that i
like yeah i here's the thing is is that
you know i
if i get more if i get bigger than i am
i think i'm going to like become more
weird
oh but it's contrived it doesn't matter
i'm gonna have like dirt on my face for
no reason you know what i mean it's it's
forced you're not that weird you have a
people thing
he wants to give the perception i do say
that man but like
i'm cool but everybody here likes you
i'm weird and cool too man i mean but
you are cool you're a birkenstocks guy
and just admit just admit it yeah what
you love birkenstock i like that one
pair because that's camo on it okay my
point is is that um
i mean but here's the thing though it's
when people when i'm being myself
people still go
he's eccentric yeah like when i was you
you kind of have an eccentric guy yeah
for sure and like even at the show
somebody said yeah some of the
executives said that you were eccentric
i go why
because
you know you know how table reads go
like everyone's there is a single camera
show yeah okay so the president of like
the studio yeah right they're all there
everyone's there
the cast everybody
and what i do is we had this room
and i waited for everyone to sit down
and i was the last guy to sit down and i
would be there the first i'd be the
first guy there and i would just wait i
would just wait in the back
and wait for people to sit down
and then i would sit when we started
and people thought that that was
being artsy and weird i think that
you're for sure neurotic but i don't
know if you need to add the twitches you
know what i mean just for
no don't do that
single glove with the fingers yeah you
start showing up like that the table
reads they're going to be like anybody
we can write this guy
because i don't know if you guys can see
where's the glue is there glue around oh
i know what you do what you would you
would pour it dry it and peel your hands
yeah but i would do it at table rates
anyway in front of the network what
would they say i would have three
bottles of elmer's glue and i would just
drip them on my hands and do this and
just let it dry and do my read like that
yeah and they were just like this guy's
crazy yeah but you loved it yeah
it kind of feels like i don't know it
feels like a compliment right
there's something in our heads it's like
like my wife's always like you to me
she'll be like when i laugh at [ __ ]
she's like you have mental problems i
think you're a psycho and i go
i think it's funny yeah i think it's
funny yeah
when she says it i mean sometimes other
people say it they're like you're really
[ __ ] up and i'm like
yeah
yeah yeah i think it's great it is gross
that i force myself to do certain things
but especially to impress a girl no i do
it in even in public like i'll i'll do
gibberish
to pretend i don't know how to speak the
language so date number six
then we drive we get in a van we drive
like an hour and a half
into tulum
and you know
we get to the we have airbnb
yeah yeah everybody's nice it's nice
hotel no hotel dude i'm telling you guys
this was a perfectly nice penthouse it
had two bedrooms there was a pool in the
roof it was
very it was like a it was a chill place
but when we got there the first thing
bobby said was
ah this is what camping feels like
this [ __ ] diva it's camping why is it
like catholic because the outside
felt like the inside
oh i needed an environment shift
i see what do you mean there was ac no
but it wasn't on at the time
so what happens if there's no gas they
obviously turn it off to save save money
money and um
so you walked in it was as humid in
there as it was outside
so i'm like okay
and then it looks kind of modern and
stumped
but
you know you could tell that we're still
in the middle of the jungle yeah in the
middle of the jungle and you're not i'm
not gonna have the same
wi-fi speed
oh [ __ ] no games
not good no games you can't download
anything but
i was exhausted anyways so
i would no we would have we went out
that night yeah we went to go so we went
to so here's why tulum's great okay is
we go into
what's that street called
by the um by the beach all the hotels
tillam beach tulum beach
and
you could just already tell that it's
you see like rich white hippies walking
around
you see the stores are like high-end
we're in portland right but not too
high-end they're not